ça c'est une voiture 100% électrique
c'est la leaf de nissan
on se la teste aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
c'est franchement cool wasquehal un
triptan plusieurs jours premier jour on
est à vélizy 2 non loin de paris pour
aller découvrir un peu un concept store
créé par nissan c'est une boutique de
notre genre c'est franchement génial
deuxième point on va se faire un tour à
paris et puis c'est sympa paris c'est
bien mais on a besoin d'air on a besoin
de grands espaces et elaia des grands
espaces
bienvenue dans nos veines on se teste la
leaf 100% électrique dans un cadre juste
ou fissible là derrière vous avez appuyé
la voir pas ici l'arc
vous avez le puy-de-dôme il ya encore un
petit peu de neige sur le haut c'est top
et pour respirer le grand air et plus
profité de la pollution la leaf s'écoule
et en plus ici
on est drôlement bien
[Musique]
je vous emmène aujourd'hui à vélizy 2
pas très loin de paris un peu plus au
sud il ya un truc assez exceptionnel
juste devant moi vous ne voyez pas
encore vous avez un store d'un autre
genre c'est un nouveau store de nice
alpes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on n'est pas sur une boutique
éphémère on n'est pas sur une boutique
qui arrive qui ferment je fais comme à
la maison
cette boutique nissan elle va rester en
place elle va s'agrandir et l'idée c'est
que entre un tour avec votre caddie par
là et prada vous allez découvrir une
marque sous un autre angle
mais bon avec moi là vous découvrez la
gamme nissan donc bon alors sans vous
parler découvrir les gammes salle parce
que j'imagine que là vous vous la
connaissez déjà
vous avez un écran tactile vous avez la
gamme vous avez la leaf on va en parler
on va tester parce que hyper
intéressante de ce côté là à la
différence je dirais d'un parcours en
concession où on va venir plus dans une
démarche mercantile
là on vient vous voir en disant ah bah
tiens vous venez de découvrir ce qu'on
fait découvrir les innovations qu'est-ce
qui se passe goyette chez nissan
ici pas de vendeurs que des ambassadeurs
qui vous accueille
[Musique]
là vous pouvez voir un petit peu bien à
quoi pourrait ressembler votre voiture
en fonction de la teinte que vous allez
pouvoir choisir vous allez pouvoir
choisir votre intérieur ça c'est cool et
ensuite vous pouvez le vérifier
directement sur un seul même et grand
écran tactile vous choisissez votre
véhicule le configurateur et là vous
allez venir créer votre véhicule de a à
z
or là tout le monde voit ce que vous
faites et si vous être un petit peu plus
discret vous avez votre tablette là vous
mettez dans le coin et ce qu'ils
écoulaient ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'en 14 jours votre voiture peut
être chez vous selon les paramètres que
vous avez choisi donc c'est une nouvelle
approche une nouvelle façon de concevoir
l'automobile et c'est vraiment ça qui
est intéressant est le tour de force qui
est fait par nissan on n'approche pas le
consommateur de la manière on se met
disponible dans un endroit de vie qui
est autrement ici et là vélizy 2 juste
au sud de paris
il y en aura d'autres on aura d'autres
dans le monde entier là c'est une
première c'est la toute première fois et
si vous êtes intéressé vous sélectionnez
vous commencez à créer votre véhicule et
vous terminez chez vous pouvez même
passé la commande a pris enfin c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est une approche
complètement différente très novatrice
et en plus ça les techno qui sont hyper
passionnante
ça y est vous le montrez on va aller
faire un tour de la leaf jeu pas si vous
vous intéressez à l'automobile si vous
avez un petit peu regardé ce qui se
passait du côté de chez nissan et
notamment sur la leaf c'est assez
hallucinant
il voit dans le parking ici vous avez
les voitures qui peuvent être essayés
dans le cadre justement ou du concept
store nissan qui est juste au dessus
l'idée c'est que vous êtes là bas vous
découvrez vos dit je veux l'essayer
vous pouvez directement tout est ici
c'est très rapide et ça franchement
c'est hyper pratique
donc là on est en train de faire un
essai au tour de vélizy donc à paris
donc je te concentrer son art ou quand
même je regarde pas trop il ya plein de
modes qui sont vraiment intéressants au
niveau déjà de la boîte de vitesses vous
avez le mode d où la voiture va être
plus on roule et donc vous allez gérer
votre accélération de freinage un peu
standard le mode b quand vous mettez
dessus la voiture savall a freiné en
fait naturellement pour récupérer
d'énergie c'est cool et puis là il ya un
mois qui est génial c'est le mode i
pédales en gros avec la seule [ __ ]
d'accélération vous allez gérer les
francs le frein moteur en fasse un truc
vraiment très intelligente en tout cas
ce qui est génial avec cette voiture
c'est que dès que vous appuyez points
ces couples c'est vraiment ça kg avec de
l'électrique pourquoi on les sent
autoroute se sentant plus concentrés
devant sens l'a86 je sais le propane lot
alors le truc est vraiment très très
impressionnant c'est à dire qu'il faut
bouger toujours une main sur le volant
de ces mieux habilité à 10h10 comme l
auto-école voulons pas bougé tout seul
en route donc il va reconnaître les
filles aussi un franchissement ligne et
que vous avez pas fait attention ça va
sauter si vous lâcher le volant il faut
bien sûr pas faire il va vous alerter
d'abord il va faire du bruit
laâbi paix mais ensuite il vous fait
revivre un peu tout ça l'idée c'est que
vous voulez c'est que c'est tout cas
vous avez un problème
il va vous réveiller il va vous remettre
en place dans votre rôle de conducteur
et ont su que la voiture m trois grands
coups de frein par pas grand chose à
jeter contre les murs mais trois coups
de frein pour vos fichiers en gros vous
réveiller cette fois ça va pas la
voiture s'arrête est mêlé barney ils
m'ont plu presque un ps courant faute de
quoi ça c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressant et se compare yacht est
génial parce que en fait ça vous
facilite la conduite ça va pas conduire
à votre place ça vous regarde sur les
voies ça va tourner le volant ça va
réguler votre vitesse en fonction des
véhicules qui vont être devant que
derrière
mais ça marche quasiment tout seul
gardien l'affranchissement je me remets
en place le truc est franchement hyper
hyper hyper cool maintenant ce que je
vous propose c'est que l'on sorte un
petit peu de l'environnement parisien
on va aller s'oxygéner on allait au bon
air on va quitter un peu la pollution du
coin et on va essayer ça vous allez voir
ça va juste être hallucinant
a réussi on lave pas la voiture
maintenant on peut rester des heures
on va rester des heures bon là on se
fait un petit tour on est avec la bonne
équipe on est parti dans un spot hyper
cool on est parti dans les volcans
d'auvergne pour vraiment 3 posté
l'électrique et j'ai envie on abat team
d'intelligent avec moi donc là c'est
beaucoup plus sympa le but aujourd'hui
c'est quand même de commencer avec une
belle voiture bien propre donc on
commence on passe aux carreaux ajoncs la
lave et on va se faire une bonne balade
dans les volcans des sûr qu'on n'a pas
redressé dedans pendant le salon non
compris
[Musique]
ok
on n'a pas nui
auj
pas
le bloc ne craint pas que je t'écrase ça
va je suis un proposant une fille
ce cas
sow
johnny mowlem stable la cclat voiture et
en descente elle en train de traîner
tout seul et là du coup si je prenne un
peu parce qu'on est sans montagne
forcément du volcan est malade ce cem
récupère en termes d'autonomie donc la
jcat 59% je suis passé à 60 pour son
autonomie en très peu de temps donc en
finale en mon temps je consomme et en
descendant je récupère et ça parce qu'on
sait qu'on
m
non
on joue ta faim écoute je sais pas je
trouve un bon petit resto dans mon coin
pour ce que j'en ai vu un passé par là
bas c'est d'abord cela fait qu'à soi
tout en fait ce film et les mêmes plans
catalent aulas auberge de la pac
géraldine l'aubrière savait pas mal
parce que vu les kilomètres qu'on
abordait soit un bond de faire du bien
marine le pen
qui ont besoin c'était pas mal ah
c'était pas mal toujours aussi belle ce
qui n'est pas ton cas
ce pas
foot
bye
suite
non elle est silencieuse c'est pas la
peine de faire jouer ce match là bas
ça m'a dit de voter coûte rien c'est
génial ça qui ouvre en fait tu vois
c'est avec des voitures comme ça bah
t'as pas de bruit mais ça change
vraiment de ce qu'on peut retrouver sur
une voiture classique
et c'est vraiment ça que j'adore au delà
des différents modes de conduite qu'on
va voir le proprio est juste
exceptionnelle lorsque vous êtes sur
l'autoroute le ils pédalent que j'adore
aussi les coûts avec ce véhicule c'est
déjà le côté hyper ce silencieux très
calme atmosphère plutôt zen
ça part vite le but est pas de foncer
comme une fusée mais franchement on est
une très belle reprise on sent vachement
sécurité lorsqu'on veut doubler et qu'on
abandonne 1 la route ris tout de suite
on et puis ça va directement
moi je suis plutôt enthousiaste j'aime
beaucoup la voiture je pense que votre
sueur électrique on continuera d'en
parler on pensé quoi les guys voilà pour
ce tour un livre j'espère que ça vous
aura plu de dévoués un petit peu en même
temps je vous ai oxygène et puisqu'on
fait de l'électrique ans ou dans les
endroits dans les grands espaces
je tiens le volant on s'oxygène ça fait
du bien comment vous la trouvez vous
cette voiture la nissan leaf parce que
vous ne trouvez intéressante
et qu'est ce que vous pensez que la
voiture électrique commence et que c'est
vraiment l'automobile du futur
qu'est ce que vous pensez que ça ait une
grosse question qu'est ce que vous
pensez du nouveau store que vous avez à
vélizy 2 de nissan nous invite à marquer
tout ça bien évidemment on va en
commentaires qu'on vous parle je regarde
ma route parce qu on te regarde en
auvergne ça tourne de tous les côtés
vous marquez tout ça je vous remercie
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo 150 me à
beaune aujourd'hui c'est juste
monstrueux je vous embrasse
à très bientôt soyez sages prenez soin
de vous et achat des pouces à bientôt
tommy lee concilium écrasé
m